he wrote that great piece and everyone
talked about and about how you all these
years bet and you just didn't this year
yes Christian I should apologize the
last time I looked at you you were
playing against West Ham I was sitting
somewhere above you I'm shouting YouTube
to run even harder than you already were
which was hard but I was somebody who
for years I think probably around 20
years I'd always bet on Leicester to win
20 pounds and I failed to do it last
year because I moved to America but I
gather you're got moved to America at
some time as well yeah that that's
definitely my plan I had my family over
in New York which are here at the moment
it's nice to have them around when
things are happening to simply share
this moment with them of success and
yeah definitely at some point the
earlier later I will be in America
Christian the thing I've been asked
about a lot here is are there any kind
of management business lessons from
Leicester and what I normally say is I
say it's a mixture between amazing
teamwork but also some some kind of
science in terms of buying people very
cheaply do you think there's an element
of that you famously came in for not
much money I don't I can't really tell
if this is the right where the other one
is the right way I think right now we we
simply have the right type of characters
the right type of people in this team
which simply form a great team on the
field on Astor Fierman it's a lot of you
know governor is giving us a lot of
freedom also besides playing football or
soccer sorry and you know it's simply
enjoyable you enjoy the time you're
having fun together and I think that's a
big key to success and should I bet you
in the Champions League next year yeah
well that's another story you know I'm
just right now I'm really looking
forward to Lister trophy on Saturday
Christine can you hold on to your top
talent I mean can Leicester hold on to
you know the likes of Rd and Marez next
season will you stick together
well I can tell you that I will stay I
don't know what their plans are but you
know I think
they really know what the club is all
about they appreciate the chance that
they had a half at this club and you
know we playing champions like League
next year so yeah I think they know less
than the chance I think won't be
happening to us man I think they want to
be a part of that as well